all right we want to get to a developing
story this morning because obviously
some of this is what uh protesters those
in the trucker convoy have been uh
calling for and of course it's been
causing major issues in ottawa and now
at border crossings here's global's sean
o'shea he joins us this morning from one
of north america's busiest crossings the
ambassador bridge which of course
connects windsor to detroit but not much
getting through right now sean good
morning and what is the latest where
you're
at jeff and carolyn uh good morning uh
the latest is the the pickup hockey game
behind me i'm not sure what the score is
but they've been doing that for the last
half hour or so part of this sort of
very festive atmosphere here among the
protesters who have been camped out here
since uh monday
but the reality is the most important
part of this is that trucks are not able
to get into canada from the united
states you're right this is the big one
this is the big bridge about 27
of all economic activity between the two
countries from a trade perspective
crosses this bridge and so it is very
significant and since monday no traffic
coming into canada uh the bridge has uh
the the trucks that would normally come
across here have had to divert to
another bridge at sarnia ontario about
two hours from here it's much smaller it
doesn't have the capability to handle as
much of this traffic but really without
this bridge without this key crossing
point
you know canadian businesses whether
you're making uh cars
whether you're
stocking grocery shelves whether you're
bringing in medical supplies
most of the stuff comes across this
bridge and these protesters and they're
relatively few in number 40 or 50 trucks
and you know 100 or so protesters
they've been able to shut it all down
yeah
what it is doing to the shipment of
goods i mean the last couple of years it
has already been bad enough this is just
adding insult to injury i don't know if
my fridge is in one of those trucks
because um you know i've been waiting a
year for that fridge and the appliance
store where i bought it they haven't
been able to make a sale because they're
waiting for all of these appliances to
come in
okay a
similar blockade happening in kutz
alberta now sean in light of today's
developments in alberta and saskatchewan
with the dropping of vaccine mandates
and soon mask mandates
are the truckers at all talking about
this advancement is this swain any of
them to wrap this up anytime soon
no carolyn we talked to
the protesters yesterday and i i'm going
to be careful of my language because i'm
getting emails from people saying don't
call these people truckers and because a
lot of the truckers who are waiting in
line they're the ones that are working
and trying to make those deliveries and
get your fridge and all that kind of
stuff
but it doesn't make a difference they
told us yesterday they want mandates
dropped they want them dropped right now
nothing is fast enough and so um you
know they're equipped enough to be able
to stay here for a while uh you you laid
it all out uh what different provinces
are doing and starting to do but they're
making this point that they want it all
done right now and they have the upper
hand because they got in here they got
set up and you know from a policing
perspective we can talk about that if
you want but they're in position here
and unless somebody requires them to
leave they've said they're not going to
leave
all right shawn o'shea at the ambassador
bridge for us this morning with the very
latest sean appreciate this thank you